three drivers died in three
different crashes here in the valley how are
you greeted by cristian casseres according to
the nevada police one of the
drivers died when his car
overturned near samoa on the parkway near
durango on monday an engine and a
motorcyclist are between  another of
the fatalities when he collided with a
truck that was traveling on the street on the
way to north and umh mount in the
other fatal accident was recorded
near lake mead and brain park streets a
man is recovering in the
hospital after an altercation with the
police the shooting involved a
uniformed
officer the metro police department says that the confrontation
between the officer and the subject was
caused after a
fight between two men was reported near the
street mails reports but when one
of the officers arrived  men threw himself at one of the
officers and was seen attempting to direct
his hand into one of his pockets at
which point officers thought  They reported that
the man was trying to take out a weapon and
open a fire. The man was injured
as well as the officer. Until now,
it is unknown if the man was armed.
Work begins to clean up the
debris from the incident that destroyed a
historic hotel on the Tauste mountain in
Last September, this
cleaning phase is expected to be completed by the end of the
month. Owners of the property say they have
plans to rebuild and one of the most
anticipated music festivals announced
its artistic cast. We talked about live es
piropo that will take place in various
stages  for three days in
downtown las vegas among the long list
of artists are the competing arctic monkeys
and loor among others the sale
of tickets to the public begins this
friday and the cost for the three days
starts at 380 dollars per person and
a  nice day with temperatures
higher than normal this Tuesday will be
the only day of the week with digits in
the 80s then we will see u  n small
drop in temperatures at
the beginning of spring we will have
some cloudy days during the
week despite the fact that most will be
sunny days in the 70 degrees I am cristian
casseres with your brief news from
ignis now in spanish good day